I haven't seen a lot of [ __ ] bro for
real like it just got to a point where I
couldn't live with my grandmother my
grandmother died in 2016 bro I missed
the last probably year and a half of my
grandmother life because I couldn't live
up I couldn't live that bro I couldn't
live that [ __ ] was trying to kill me I
couldn't you couldn't be around her
because you couldn't be around the
person who I love the most because my
life because of where she lived right
and she ain't had no choice she don't
[ __ ] section eight right she can't
move you feel I'm saying like that [ __ ]
bothered me still to this day bro and I
don't want to get emotional about it but
you can only imagine like that's just
one thing so how about this so my
grandma died of covet early cover yeah
so but this is what was [ __ ] up if she
was like
teetering on dementia so we'd have to go
and see her
like three or four times a week just to
remind her right so she would always if
my grandmother was like that she had a
stroke she had a stroke and she was like
you know trying to gain her memory back
you know yeah but what was crazy was you
remember during covert they shut down
all the um the nursing homes so like the
last two months of my grandma's life we
literally were not allowed to visit her
that's crazy and they wouldn't they
wouldn't even like they would try to put
us on the phone with her you know what
I'm saying but like so she died Alone
with nobody around her without seeing
anybody for two months crazy bro I ain't
gonna lie and like I relate to that
because and I only want to get deep into
it you know what I'm saying but
I'ma just go into it [ __ ] it
my mother's mom she died from a stroke
her second stroke I caused a first
stroke I got into a fight at school when
I was in eighth grade [ __ ] and I told my
sister like run down the block and my
sister had a cell phone right we getting
into some [ __ ] after school blase blah
I tell my sister like run down the
street you know what I'm saying and
my sister called like oh her been
fighting and scared my grandmother like
you know made her get scared and as soon
as I walk in the house after the [ __ ] I
walk home I'm in eighth grade soon as I
walk in the house my grandma see me she
already like ecstatic like she's already
[ __ ] yeah it's older [ __ ] though
it's older than we got into some [ __ ]
that was like Junior seniors ice cream
we in eighth grade you feel I'm saying
so my my sister crying on the phone she
is static my grandma don't know what the
[ __ ] going on right so when I get home
and she see me walk in she like already
paranoid I promise I went in the house
for two minutes okay I fell on the floor
hit a stroke in front of everybody you
feel me and she recovered from it she
had surgery she lost her memory all that
you know what I'm saying and then she
had another
another
um another stroke maybe like
10 years later something like that you
know what I'm saying but like as I'm in
the streets and all this and I had to
move out of my grandmother's house and I
was still trying to like go see her you
know I remember my last time stepping
foot in my grandmother house I was
probably 18 19 years old my last time
stepping foot in her house
um
and I had a girl like drop me off like
I'm gonna go see my grandma real quick
right pulling me right there and my Ops
neighborhood it's just me and the girl
you feel me wow I go inside the crib I
got a big ass gun on me
big ass gun on me my grandma see it you
feel me like
she like don't come back here no more
you know I only want you to come back
here no more yeah it's cool I'll call
you I'll come see you if I'm saying and
that was the last time I went to my
grandma's house and then I moved my
mother when I started making money the
first thing I did the first big check I
really got for real I moved my mama out
the hood right I knew my grandma wasn't
moving she ain't going nowhere I'm with
my grandma an hour away from Chicago my
grandma already sick she old she not
driving an hour away to go see nobody
you feel me like my grandma only been in
my the mansion and I bought my mama my
grandma probably been there I could
count on one hand how many times she's
been there you feel me and
it was like I lost their memories with
my grandmother and that's who raised me
that's the woman I love the most you
feel me I lost those memories and what
I'm saying is I'll relate to what you're
saying because this is my mother's Mom
after covet my father's mom still I
haven't seen my father's mom in probably
two years right she's in a hospital
still to this day right now right now we
don't know what I'm doing hey she's in
the hospital to this day she called
covet and she was in like one of them
spots where covet was so crazy she
couldn't get no visitors yeah that's
what she's limited visitors can't nobody
even see her but my mom my mom only see
her maybe once or twice right my dad
could only go see her they won't even
let me see her I'm G herbo I can't even
go see my grandmother for real you know
what I'm saying like and I think now I
probably can now but it's like it's two
years and gone by my grandma
close to 80 years old right you feel I'm
saying she like 77 78
close to 80 years old I can't even see
it you know what I'm saying that [ __ ]
with me all the time go see her man if
you can only Grandma yeah I don't even
know if I can I've been trying to hit
myself like I would go back home to the
AZ because I'm from Phoenix and I would
be like I would always make an
appointment I would always say anything
about me I promise like I want to go
take my kids to go see her bro that's
the [ __ ] that really means something to
me you know what I'm saying like I got a
one-year-old and a four-year-old
daughter you know what I'm saying like I
want to take all my kids my son four
years old you know of course you met
your son a bunch of times I need to go
take all my kids to go see her that's
what's important she want to see her
grandkids yeah these are great and it'll
make a great grandkid and it'll make her
life it'll make her [ __ ] my grandma a
soldier you know what I'm saying so
that's a lot like a lot of [ __ ] that I
battle wouldn't I be dealing with bro
and dealing with my family and [ __ ] like
oh never really say it you know but I'm
open to say it now because I want people
to understand like I don't speak on this
[ __ ] so when you come to me with your
problems I got my own problems of course
I don't want to hear another [ __ ]
problems bro because I deal with my
problems head on and your problems
probably not even half of what I'm
dealing with and I got all the money I'm
dealing with More Money More Problems
but [ __ ] the money yeah I got my own
personal problems don't come to me about
no personal problems and I got these
problems in them problems you know what
I'm saying I'm telling you man you got
to go see what you're dealing with a lot
of [ __ ] bro I definitely wanna I
definitely have to you know like I talk
because I I've been thinking in my head
I'd be like [ __ ] I wish I would have
went and saw her more I talked to my mom
every day about this [ __ ] you know talk
to my dad it's like I have to I don't I
like right now literally if I'm able to
go visit my old grandmother it just
happened like this a week recently yeah
two weeks I just got the window to go
see yeah those nursing homes they're
being very careful that [ __ ] wasn't like
that bro I couldn't see it right um just
now able to so I gotta take initiative
right now if I'm saying it that should
be tough it's crazy what you said about
like not being able to go see your
grandma because where she lived
exactly I just wonder how many like just
countless countless countless young men
are dealing with that same [ __ ] you know
I mean [ __ ] in Chicago can't go see
their grandmother Grand they mother
their kids because where they live you
know what I'm saying it that's why it's
so big on me to just bring opportunity
and change to the city you know what I'm
saying because if you don't bring no
opportunity [ __ ] is not beefing in
Chicago over money especially my
generation it ain't no money out there
[ __ ] Ain't beefing over no blocks or
drug lines and none of that [ __ ] [ __ ]
beefing over here say [ __ ] the
internet lack of money lack of
opportunities nothing to do but be angry
at everybody but once you start bringing
money on give a [ __ ] and it's my opinion
because I've experienced money and I
maybe I'm wrong or maybe I'm not right
but once you start bringing money and
opportunity to [ __ ] Ain't nobody got
time to do that [ __ ] Bro once you got
millions and you can feed your family
you don't want to go do nothing no [ __ ]
so if you're doing that for this and for
whoever like just bring an opportunity
to Chicago a lot of violence is going to
stop because [ __ ] gonna be able to
take care of their family if I'm saying
like [ __ ] could talk out differences
or whatever fight hit whatever you know
I'm not trying to end all the violence
it's impossible to never end all the
violence anywhere not just Chicago but
like I'm just trying to bring
opportunity to the youth so they don't
have to do that so even my generation we
probably already too [ __ ] up to be
honest maybe I don't know but definitely
the newest generation is I care about
the youth I care about the generations
after me so they don't got to live How I
Live you know what I'm saying that's
what's important to me I want my kids to
live highly bro I want my kids to have
their innocence to have their youth